hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice short game uh from round three of
the 2021 video world cup it's magnus
crosston versus uh fellow norwegian
aryan toddy and
features a tactic that you should really
know in case you run into it
because it's a very nasty one if you
happen to well fall for it
uh much like what happened in this game
so without further ado let's check it
out and see what
this is about so magnus has the white
pieces and this is game one of their
classical match so let me just switch
this
r to a c because i know you guys uh
really started paying attention to what
i'm doing
there we go uh one more click all right
there we go so now
now we have a c uh magnus with the white
pieces
opens with c4 he goes for the english
opening with e6
uh g3 now and d5 so black taking control
the center and magnets will uh will try
to control the
the center from the from the flank uh
this is the agincourt defense uh we have
bishop to g2 and now
d captures on c4 we have queen to a for
check
going to uh well recollect this pawn we
have c6 and
queen captures and c4 and now uh usually
what white uh
what black just plays here is b5 but
here tari played c5 it's not a new movie
that has been played a few times
uh but um in the games where it was
played known moves are knight to f3 and
the d3 but magnus here plays uh
pawn to b3 he prepares to fiance the
other bishop as well
and it is now already as of move six
that we have a completely new game so
let's see how tari
uh deals with this b3 idea uh we have
knight to f6
bishop to b2 uh we have bishop to e7
preparing the castle and
now knight to f3 we have knights to c6
in here
both players just cast so castles
castles and now
knight to e5 magnus already putting some
pressure here
as the knight here is attacked twice and
uh you don't really have a good way to
defend this knight so it's best just to
capture the
uh the knight on e5 so knight captures
bishop captures
and now knight to d7 uh kicking away the
the dark square bishop we have bishop
back to b2
and now rook to b8 so you can start
pushing your b
pawn so if you could get b5 in would be
very nice so magnus
develops the knight while defending the
b5 square and now
bishop to f6 uh countering white's a
very strong dark square bishop here
uh
uh a dark square bishop here so here we
have rook a to b1 now if the knight
moves the bishop here will be protected
and now b6 and as you can see here the
position is
uh roughly equal not much is happening
here and uh it seems the magnus decided
to to take um
uh well a slow maneuvering game from
round one and then
depending on what happens uh he is going
to try and do something else in round
two
and the black of course welcomes this
decision as well it seems to be an easy
draw and then he will
take his chances with the white pieces
so here magnus plays
b4 uh he wants to create some something
here on the queen side with bishop to b7
black continues developing
and now we have a series of trades we
have characters captures
captures and now knight captures on c5
uh we have bishop to a3 now opening the
knight the rook is still on f8 and here
we have rook the c7 and this rook the c7
is very interesting
it seems like white is kind of
threatening captures captures and rook
captures on b7 but uh if black really
wanted
black could go for queen captures on d2
it's a really funny line
uh the thing is after bishop captures on
c5 you don't capture here you play rook
to c7
and now we get this knight to e4 move
attacking the queen
and the defending the bishop and also
attacking the bishop on f6 so the black
queen would have to go all the way back
now comes queen c1 again with the threat
of
queen captures queen g captures and then
you win the bishop here
so queen to g6 and now we eliminated
this guy with check now
even though queen captures looks like
the something you want to do
it's actually g captures what you want
to do here because you want to
leave this square open for your king now
white will capture the rook
and after black grabs the queen we're
first going to capture here rook
captures on b1 king captures here
and now rook to c8 check and now if you
capture with the queen here instead of
the pawn then you'd have to play king
here then we would pick up this pawn
with check but now the king can go here
and the game kind of continues and it's
very unclear uh black
black should be better here because of
the two pawns but
it's uh you know most likely a draw uh
so you know
it's possible to grab this pawn however
uh tarry played
rook to c7 not allowing any any such
tricks uh and now
rook f2d1 by magnus now uh
there are of course a lot of things you
could play here you could try and maybe
eliminate
this knight here and then pile up on the
c file uh but we have rook to e8
just getting away from that diagonal and
now
knight to b5 attacking the rook here so
rook to d7 you kind of still have to
keep an eye on this pawn
uh but now bishop captures on c5b
captures and queen to a4
offering this pawn for this pawn uh so
here we have queen
a8 defending this pawn twice and now
d3 magnus also defends his spawn and
stops the past
c pawn from going any further here we
have
h5 tarry now controls this beautiful
diagonal
and he would very much like to play h4
h3 and checkmate magnus and g2 here
so rook d to c1 and now rook to c8
defending the c5 phone and now
knight back to a3 by magnus of course
black doesn't have a b
pawn or a d pawn so you would very much
enjoy putting your knight on c4
it will remain there since black will
not have any pawns to challenge it so
here rook to d4 attacking carlson's
queen
knight to c for now we have h4
and now magnus has to deal with this h3
and queen uh
g2 checkmate are coming and if you don't
want to start weakening your position
too much
uh you have to deal with this so queen
to b5 ready to meet h3 with queen to b7
so now queen to d5 but still magnus goes
queen to b7
attacks the queen here and the rook so
rook to d8 and now magnus uh trades
queen so we have captures um
uh here and now pawn captures uh forcing
the knights to move
knight to e3 and now rook to a4 putting
pressure on the a2 pawn
so rook to c2 and magnus defends it and
now
h3 so it's a very very interesting
position magnus doesn't want his king to
be stuck here so king to f1 at some
point you will have to move the knight
probably play
e2 and to get some breathing room for
the king otherwise your back rank is
still very weak so here bishop to d4
uh but now knight to f5 attacking the
bishop bishop back to f6 and now
knight to e3 and here magnus says is
seemingly repeating moves atari
uh would be very very uh satisfied with
the draw
uh because he gets the white pieces in
the next game so here in knight f5
bishop to f6
and now magnus says all right i'm still
gonna try for something rook captures on
c5 let's trade pawns here
we have rook captures on a2 now tari
with the past a pawn
and now knight back to ae3 going after
the pawn here
and now a5 and it's interesting uh
if you try bishop to d4 here now kind of
trying to
do some damage then rook captures on d5
uh you know it's just much
much better for white uh and if you do
something like rook to e8
well then it's perfectly fine for black
because it's a very tricky
move uh you can't capture a pawn with
your knight because then this rook
comes crashing down to e2 and if rook
captures
then you play a5 and then well it's uh
again a very good position for black
you're just going to start advancing
your past pawn
the bishop already covers the queening
square and the knight can never move
because we'll just root catch us on e2
so it would be
um the the bishop here would simply be
much better than night and
you know being upon up for white
wouldn't really matter here uh but okay
atari played a5 right away without
this rook to e8 move and now magnus
grabs the pawn
knight captures on d5 but now it's much
different the bishop here is already
hanging not hanging but
the knight is attacking it so bishop to
d4
attacking the rook we have rook seattle
not there
obviously uh rook c to b5 and here
uh atari uh well kari's position is not
as great as
the position that we've checked out when
the rook came to e8
but uh it's still playable however here
he played e
a4 and he completely missed what carlson
had in mind
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to uh find
this the thing that is the oldest trick
in the book while i give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting all the
mating patterns and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
knight to e7 check and it was in this
position on move 40 that arientari
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is
it doesn't matter where the king goes to
if you go here or here
it's completely the same the thing is
the knight controls these two squares
and the king
is without an escape route and then rook
to h5 will simply be checkmate
and it doesn't help or king they cheat
uh runs into the exact same thing and
kink the f8
runs into the very nasty knight to c6
with an attack on the rook and the
bishop but also
the knight controls the e7 square so the
rook can never
leave the back ring to keep an eye on
the bishop if you try and keep an eye on
the bishop rook b8 runs into checkmate
you again have to block and this will
now be checkmate
the e7 square is covered by the knight
uh and
if you don't do this um after this
night knight to c6 well then you're just
gonna lose material uh
because well you kind of have to keep an
eye on the rook if you move the rook
you're going to lose the bishop so
your best hope is just bishop f6 but
then we simply uh
win material knight captures bishop
captures and now rook to b8
uh it's a game over even though black
has a pass pawn here it doesn't really
do anything like say king
or or maybe even the king here we're
gonna play rook here
prepare rook to b8 and that's it there's
not much to be done here for example if
a3
we're going to play e3 first we don't
want to run into some back rank
uh issues and then after lasik king d7
we're just going to force the king back
in here king here rook here and then
we're going to win the bishop and that's
it
there's no the possibility for for black
to even do something here
so really a nice trick always remember
this one the knight when on e7 controls
these two squares
and uh well it's uh the the same on
all parts of the board but you know if
the king gets uh if the king gets here
then these two squares are controlled
and then you will easily deliver
checkmate it's a very
uh famous pattern because sometimes okay
imagine there's a queen on the board and
imagine that there's a pawn here
maybe you can sacrifice um you know
something here let's say you sacrifice a
queen king captures
then you deliver a check with the rook
king goes back to g8 and then you
deliver knight to e7 checkmate even
ideas like these are possible and you
you might run into them very often
uh if you know uh you ought to be
looking for them
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that many of you found
this knights the e7 idea magnus also won
the second classical game so
uh their classical game ended by uh by
magnus winning the match
and so i don't forget uh let me just
show you guys um who
is still in the tournament in round four
uh let me just uh check real quickly
uh just have to remember what i
called it uh i called it pairings yes
what else would
would you call it because they are
pairings let me just
load that all right
there we go all right so pairings are
here let me just enlarge this a little
bit so uh it's feed ace tweet
on twitter uh saying uh who is who is
left in the
uh in the tournament so uh in in round
four uh we will have wojciech versus
carlson esipenko versus dubov
makrot versus poncratov cindaro versus
piorun korobo versus grishogduda versus
idani shiong versus vidit
abdustoro versus durabili andreikin
versus
tabatabay versus harikrishna martyrosia
versus berkich
uh pragnanda versus maxime bashir
lagrave and all in all uh
french clash uh ferocity of kovalev
karakin artemis fielder vitogov and
yumab and shankland so those are the 32
players that are left in the world cup
and it's going to be a very interesting
one as
also the world champion is is is still
in there
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank stephen
wentworth uh matthew parker tom daryla
richard campbell and robert walker for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day